je fais une croix sur le graal
gastronomique
cette troisième étoile c'est c'est c'est
le rêve de dizaines et de dizaines de
chefs
mais voilà j'ai décidé de ne plus en
vouloir
des sportifs ont refusé des médailles
des acteurs ont refusé des oscars ou des
césars moi je ne veux plus de cette
étoile 50 de mes clients midi et soir
peuvent être des gens qui viennent
inspecter pour savoir si si si la maison
la cuisine est toujours à la hauteur des
attentes du guide donc ça évite
inévitablement ça crée une espèce de de
tension permanente et aujourd'hui cette
attention tout simplement je n'en ai
plus envie
ces trois étoiles ça a été un cadeau un
cadeau et demandes sont les accueillir
avec avec beaucoup de bonheur seul atout
indéniable
et mon établissement très certainement
n'aurait pas la réputation qu'il a
aujourd'hui si le guide n'avait pas été
là mais je crois qu'on l'a n'at on a là
on en a le droit je crois dans la vie de
choisir justement la vie qu'on veut
c'est trois étoiles j'étais j'étais
heureux je les ai portés mais
aujourd'hui je considère qu'elle
représente plus pour moi frais morale
comme moteur c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai envie de continuer bien
évidemment à faire exactement le même
travail que je fais jusqu'à présent me
faire plaisir dans ma cuisine avec mes
équipes en famille sur mon territoire
perdu d'aubrac
mais j'ai envie de le faire de manière
plus sereine plus détendu sans 707
tension est perceptible voilà j'ai tout
simplement envie de me mettre hors
compétition ce degré d'exigence je les
ai toujours eus je leur ai toujours
j'ai envie de continuer à travailler
dans l'excellence mais l'excellence pour
mon client
quand vous proposer à nos hôtes une
cuisine sensible humaine empreinte de
sincérité et que
vous percevez que cette émotion a été
transmise à nos clients pour moi ça
s'est grandement nommé bonheur tout
simplement